got something that might interest you  resident evil 4 gets an hd mod that  enhances the original 2014 steam edition  the mod by alfred marin includes over a  thousand texture upgrades feel the  vision slider debug menu and more so sit  back and enjoy our comparison between  the original and modded versions if  you're interested in this free mod check  out re4hd.com  enjoy  i was wondering if you might recognize  the girl in this photograph  [Music]  sorry to have bothered you  freeze  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [ __ ]  [Music]  perfect  the big cheese  what  ugh  ah  uh  so  we  kidnap the president's daughter  in order to give her our power and then  send her back  now  i think they shot something in my neck  what did you do to her  [Music]  hey it's that dog  [Music]  um  [Music]  oh  [Music]  you